Salut les amis !
Bienvenue dans Team Foufou New Life.
Vous avez un problème ? Nous trouvons la solution.
Voici Lilian.
Il est, comme qui dirait, "in love" de Sabrina.
Malheureusement, il est beaucoup trop introverti.
Objectif...
Faire de Lilian un vrai tombeur.
Let's go !
Les amis...
Bienvenue dans notre QG.
C'est ici que Lilian va devenir une toute autre personne.
Quand on regarde Lilian, une chose interpelle.
Lilian n'a aucun style.
Ouais je... J'entends par contre. Je suis là, hein.
Lilian, on s'occupe de tout.
Jeff va s'occuper de te rendre encore plus "fashion".
Fashion de chez fashion !
Let's go !
Bienvenue, Lilian, dans mon dressing.
Regarde ça ! Qu'est-ce que t'en penses ?
Je sais pas...
Ça en jette un max !
Je t'ai concocté ce qui se fait de mieux en matière de style.
Parce que, excuse-moi, mais vestimentairement parlant...
Tu ressembles plus à un pasteur qu'autre chose !
Ok.
Bien envoyé, mec.
Ah bah donc, votre plan... Pour m'aider, c'est de me rabaisser, en fait.
C'est ça... L'idée ?
Relax, mec.
Une fois qu'on t'aura relooké...
Tu seras plus stylé que le style.
Bien envoyé, Jeff.
C'est censé me rassurer cette... cette promesse ?
Ouais.
Une réponse, ça aurait été bien aussi...
Non, non.
C'est bon ?
J'ai l'impression que le crapaud s'est transformé en prince charmant !
Ça, là ! C'est bien pour vous, ça ?
Lilian a raison.
Le style ne suffit pas.
Il lui manque encore une chose pour pouvoir atteindre Sabrina.
Let's go !
L'apparence, c'est réglé.
Lilian est plus frais que frais.
Maintenant, Dustin va s'occuper d'améliorer un nouvel aspect.
Je sens que ça va splasher.
Alors Lilian...
Pour regagner un peu de confiance en toi...
Je te propose fort logiquement de... ?
Bah je sais pas. En fait, si j'avais la solution j'aurais pas besoin de vous, enfin... C'est...
De faire un battle de danse !
Ouais, j'ai pas solution mais je sais que c'est pas ça, la solution, par contre.
C'est parti !
Allez Lilian. Crève tout ! C'est la dernière étape avant d'atteindre Sabrina !
Lilian ! Lilian ! Lilian ! Lilian !
Il fait clairement honneur à sa tenue !
Il a du feu dans les pieds !!
Lilian ! Lilian ! Lilian ! Lilian ! Lilian !
Et c'est accompli les amis ! Le travail de la Team Foufou s'arrête ici.
Lilian a maintenant tout ce qu'il faut pour pouvoir conquérir Sabrina.
Ah bon ?
J'ai l'impression qu'il a toujours envie de danser !
Non, non ! C'est pas ça. Je me suis dit : "Peut-être il y avait d'autre..."
Allez, mec ! C'est parti !
C'est fini pour nous...
On se retrouve la semaine prochaine pour aider Régis, qui a du mal à trouver un job.
Régis ?!
Avec un tel nom de portier, tu m'étonnes qu'on le laisse toujours à la porte !
Lilian !
Pauvre Régis !
Hâte de le voir !